you for joining us at 11 on 8 news now
i'm brian loftis a las vegas woman still
grieving the sudden death of her husband
after he lost his life in a motorcycle
accident in march his motorcycle was the
only vehicle that crashed but the police
report says another car's involvement
led to a tragic turn of events sasha
loftis joining us tonight with more on
her message
this is the wall deborah white's husband
hit while on his motorcycle and lost his
life it's been six months since the
crash but she still believes there's
more to the case
in december we were married 40 years
debra whited shares her favorite
memories of her late husband steve it's
just been really hard for me because
nobody was expecting for him to die he
was killed in this crash while riding
his newly purchased motorcycle back in
march according to the metro police
crash report witnesses described an
unknown car that reportedly turned in
front of steve on lamb boulevard
and caused him to swerve lose control
and run into a wall
the case is closed and no charges were
filed but deborah hopes to hear from the
other person behind the wheel that day
whoever that unknown car is
that was there that night that caused
this accident to happen
they need to come forward somehow she
says she and her family still feel like
they don't have the full story there's
really not
a closure for my family on this and
that's what's upsetting about that so
they're asking for more answers to move
forward while remembering the man they
never expected to lose so soon i don't
know if i will ever
get over this police did not identify
the car that pulled in front of
whitehead here on lamb near wyoming and
did consider this a single vehicle crash
because the two did not actually collide
reporting in las vegas tonight sasha
loftis 8 news now